welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and wong has certainly emerged as
the breakout hero of phase four the
marvel cinematic universe and we should
have known this was coming based on his
hilariously met a lion in avengers end
game is that everyone
like you wanted more and after roles in
shanghai spider-man no way home and
multiverse of madness he's now in
she-hulk where wong has shown what
delightful madness the sorcerer supreme
could get up to from helping a
supervillain get out of prison and
binging the sopranos and this is us two
suing magicians out of business and
banishing demonic bat goblins back to
hell but when the dust settles from the
mephisto hints of this episode a few odd
details remain that clue is into wong's
future as a sorcerer supreme and what
threats the mcu will face in phase 5.
when wong realizes the magician donnie
blaze sent madison through hell and that
there the talking goat demon jake
mephisto sent her to comartage with a
bloody heart he knew something was
horribly wrong and not just because
madison spoiled a big twist in the
sopranos you just ruined that but the
sopranos might actually have a bit more
to do with it than we think because wong
as sorcerer supreme is alleged to have
some future knowledge of destined events
the ancient one knew as far back as 2012
that stephen strange was destined to
become a sorcerer doctor strange knew
quite a bit about the future all the
futures by using the time stone to look
at 14 million 605 alternate futures and
we just learned that wong remembers that
strange used a ruins of cough call
memory white and spiderman no way home
even if he may not remember that a kid
named peter parker was the subject of
that spell but either way he knows more
about the past present and future than
most people do but if you think about it
the plot events of the late 90s early
2000s critically acclaimed prestige tv
series might be one of the few story
lines that might still come to wong as a
surprise making watching this show is
super important to him in the 2016
doctor strange film and an infinity war
we learned how this librarian of
commerce took great enjoyment and
exposed himself to pop culture delights
from the normal world from listening to
beyonce and adele to trying out new
delhi sandoz and some ben and jerry's
ice cream but in this episode he's a few
interesting lines that tell us a lot
about the power hierarchy of the mcu
like when he tells jen we answer to a
higher power that abides by the
metaphysical laws of the time space
continuum no judge is going to take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book
book of the chanted
no the book of american
uh laws
i was going to call out jen and say it's
called the constitution but actually
it's more complicated than that there's
also state constitutions state and
federal laws state and federal statutes
hundreds of years of precedent judicial
principles so yeah it's really not as
simple as it all being in like a book of
ashanti but i find the line from wong
fascinating because it makes us wonder
what higher power wrong answers to the
go-to answer would probably be the
living tribunal who has made nearly as
many cameos in marvel face four as wong
has first as a crumbled statue head and
the void and loki then is a series of
heads in their own realm and multiverse
of madness and then as one of the seven
cosmic entities in the chamber in thor
love and thunder living tribunal would
be the godly power who oversees all
metaphysical laws of the multiverse we
also know from the 2016 film that one of
the sorcerer's weapons is the staff of
the living tribunal this
is the staff
of the living tribunal
[Music]
but also notice how wong calls it the
time space continuum which is such a fun
little inversion from what this concept
is actually called in theoretical
physics the space time continuum this
comes from einstein's theory of
relativity in which space is seen as a
dimension interwoven with time and that
time can dilate depending on your
vantage point of where you are in space
and really other than the way physicists
have chosen to codify this as space-time
there really is no reason we couldn't
call it time-space because the two
concepts are interwoven and each can
affect the other maybe the actor
benedict wong mixed it up and they just
kept it in because why not but an
argument could be made that this tells
us something about the way the sorcerers
view reality that time comes first which
makes sense as the former keepers of the
time stone and these warnings we heard
from wong and from mordo and the ancient
one about the importance of leaving the
timelines alone and unaffected so rings
of power is here which means it is time
to start filling that brain with as much
middle-earth arcana as you can there's
no better place to do that than on
audible the sponsor of this video
audible offers an incredible selection
of audiobooks across every genre from
bestsellers and new releases to
celebrity memoirs mysteries thrillers
motivation and more you'll discover
exclusive audible originals from top
celebrities renowned experts and
exciting new voices and audio and since
we're talking about rings to power i
feel like i should mention that on
audible you can hear andy circus reading
fellowship of the ring oh babysitter is
incredible
i used to be able to do that
as an audible member you could choose
one title a month to keep from their
entire catalog including the latest best
sellers and new releases all audible
members now also get access to a growing
selection of titles included with
membership that you can listen to all
you want the selection includes
audiobooks audible originals and
podcasts more get added every month the
audible app makes it easy to listen
anytime anywhere have it on your phone
and you can listen during your commute
while tidying up around the house or
while heading down to sell a brimboard's
jewelry store to get a ring of power all
your own new members can try audible
free for 30 days visit audible.com new
rockstars or text new rockstars to
500-500 which brings us to another
interesting warning from wong that he
brought up in the courtroom one man in
the mortal realm
has the ability to cause a ripple so
great it reverberates through every
dimension and that ripple through
galaxies has the ability to destroy all
life within the known and unknown
universe now wong here might have just
been making another typical dire warning
to scare everyone in the room about
reckless usage of magic and sling rings
but the guy is also speaking from
experience wong is essentially referring
here to nexus beings one person strong
enough to ripple through every dimension
something that he just faced with the
scarlet witch but again wong's wording
is interesting he first says every
dimension then says that ripple through
galaxies like him saying time space
continuum he's categorizing his sorcerer
terminology within the language of
astrophysics which reminds us of the way
that shot in the opening of the loki's
season 1 finale seemed to depict one
universe as being contained within a
black hole and then a neighboring black
hole containing another separate
universe wong might be suggesting here
that on some level the barriers between
realities do break down on an
astrophysical scale so what does all
this mean for wong and the other
sorcerers and the other marvel heroes in
phase 5. well three things at least
first i think they are bound by the laws
of the living tribunal and now that the
book of ashanti has been destroyed in
the gap junction between reality
suggesting that it might have been the
only one of these in the multiverse that
sooner or later these characters are
going to have to appeal directly to
living tribunal to rule on things don't
be surprised if we get a trial between
wong with she-hulk as a prosecutor
second wong is likely aware of kang and
the threat that kang poses to this time
space continuum the fact that wang calls
it the time space continuum tells us
that he and kang are already speaking
the same kind of negotiating terms third
i think wang was really freaked out by
that heart that madison brought back
with her from hell why did she have this
whose heart was this why did jake the
demonic talking goat send her to
camartage with it i don't think there's
any way of seeing this bloody organ
other than as a threat jake mephisto is
sending this to wong to send a message
that message could be that these
incursions are not just happening
between universes they're also happening
between universes and these surreal
fantastical realms that border those
universes realms like hell the dark
dimension the nord dimension the shadow
realm the mirror dimension the astral
plane that's essentially what wong's
referring to when he said practicing the
mystic arts without proper training not
only endangers people it risks
untethering the material and astral
planes this isn't just incursions
between the 838 reality and the 616
reality it also encourages between those
realities and the nightmarish salvador
dali painting realities that they border
that are filled with scary
interdimensional surrealist lovecraftian
beasts like the goblins we saw in this
episode and soon things like vampires
werewolves and zombies so that heart
might even belong to the soul of the
version of doctor strange that i
speculate may be trapped in hell right
now because one of those souls of the
damn totally remained in the eye of the
soul of 616 strange as he dreamwalked
into the corpse at defender strange
strange cast out many of those souls of
the damned but one turned inward and
buried itself deeper inside him that
might explain why that third eye opens
on his forehead in the final shot
strange's soul might be claimed by hell
at this moment and the master of hell is
sending his heart back to the mcu's tony
soprano as an opera to make a deal so
yeah i don't think it's that crazy to
speculate that wong's love of the
sopranos might come from him seeing
himself as part of the sopranos of the
multiverse five heads of the families
and wong is the new jersey head that the
others just [ __ ] on but like in the
final season sopranos now those heads
are starting to get whacked actually
phil leotardo's death was pretty similar
to black bolt's death
oh [ __ ]
and now wong is looking over his
shoulder thick and he might be next and
that the whole multiverse will just end
with a blackout
ah i wish i had the balls to just end
the video that way but i got some plugs
to get through follow me on tick tock
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching and don't stop
believe
[Music]
foreign